welcome to this video playing
international master cassoulet he's got
a super high rating 25 anyone but I have
a big score against the sky five wins
two losses with one draw so let's see we
got again a queue in scale and declined
written let's see what he's doing not
BDSM or c5 yeah c5 is actually quite ok
for black I mean nothing terribly wrong
with it and they haven't looked at it
for ages I've actually prefer them to
play Knight bd7 because I think I have
some better ideas that that's critics
cute he's playing the same line as the
guy before with a 60 came interesting
that seems playable for black yeah that
is kind of similar to what Kamala is
playing in that line let's let's think
for one moment him if I go he might have
something with a 5 coming with knight c6
and c5 maybe by the way I'm he doesn't
have a name in them I think I don't know
this is this do Rosso guy to for
something I am yeah II 5v5 is an awkward
move him to face my pony is hanging
now I don't like my position very much
it looks a bit sluggish 94 was
interesting here are to see 5 or this
let's say be six before 94 was
interesting e5 is to move that I'm
expecting now Wow okay what is the point
is going to d5 okay so b5 night before
95 and a to Hanks interesting
there is very tricky opening
yeah that's not very exciting the smooth
but I didn't see much didn't see
anything else but still he has to ski 5
idea not very well developed yeah it was
that was currently added this happens
jinx cheeky for yes Bishop before check
ok let's let's see in that I get get out
of this quickly I want to say something
like rook hu was stuff like that I don't
know don't like my development and only
now maybe I'm getting away with it he's
the night is hanging so I mean I don't
think he can play any kind of move fancy
stuff like look at you I don't know I
just sticks his six I guess
Andy for is hanging in some some ways I
mean okay her interesting move did not
think about that one but ok I probably
have to cancel i mean hard to imagine to
do play something else ok now he just
took the poem is even 93 I was thinking
that I mean beforehand I was thinking
that there is that was like Nazi for
maybe but they are not really not
I can take bishops is six but that's not
really helping a lot 93 how annoying
maybe I can play that okay to Queenie
four and a divorce is hanging I don't
know very tricky you played that well I
guess I was thinking this is good one
and made on g2 how tricky is that ok so
if i take but if i take here if i take
here this is this Bishop hang side if
you move that i'm going to air k Bishop
d7 it's getting kinda bored this guy's
playing the fancy moves all of the time
i came so i cannot take him i probably
have to take that now after Queenie for
find something good you know we're good
this is not good time learning what I
have to play
check Queenie to or something I don't
know but he need something concrete
otherwise i take c 7 rook a7 ok this is
what he can play but he played a very
tactical let's say a very direct fashion
in the whole time so yeah this was to be
expected route she wanted expensive but
i want to pawn him
how does he keep the pawn 27 then I play
rugby one now getting this background
yeah it's just just just a drone course
but he's got 30 seconds more gras our
third check yeah of course not check
check check oh this is a check in this
is why this time control this is silly
yeah okay whatever check
at least I get the draw at the end check
check check check stalemate man at least
the dry then yeah okay another guy on
the list of people who really don't know
I came a lot going going there um yeah
he had it he played this very nicely i
think justice from here i played that
very nicely okay took them i went here
25 okay yeah what is the the computer is
playing this move and since white is
clearly better yeah there is some point
to that we hits the Queen actually going
I did not really think about the move
after i just went Bishop b5 but there is
this is this is quite quite good right
yes to go back all the way this is this
is having no big point there yeah that
well then then castles was really stupid
Bishop c4 I did not think about it after
I went Bishop b5 the moon before that
but yeah I'm still kind of okay night
before he went here look T 1 is good now
wins the tempo I did not see them with
41 I didn't consider Bishop e7 very much
and now Queen g5 is better than this now
here really has apartment I think Jack
may be played at a bit too fancy this
kind of thing because now g7 is simply
impossible to hold
you know I didn't have rope d8 because
of the check made and okay this is just
just total draw but he tried to win on
time which fortunately for once did not
work okay well thanks for watching